[Musique]
tahar houchi sais pas pourquoi c'est
pour manger un bon c'est vrai qu'il ya
des grilles pour songer vue là j'ai vu
là dans le jt là ils ont dit vos se
laver les mains tout le temps parce que
y'a le jt fais toi tu te balades etc des
box avant le combat des gants de boxe on
imagine ccc traire et agrippe grippe et
gastro
alors attention les grandes gueules
l'egypte je vous le dis à tuer encore
beaucoup de personnages et la grippe
chaque année je sais je sais aller très
connu qui est mort de la grippe très bon
que vous êtes le spécialiste des morts
et en les chanteurs j'en connais pas
assez la grippe non d'accord merci et
d'autres questions merci très bien très
beau début d'émission a laissé partir
alors je lui ce matin dans le figaro qui
étaient les trois hommes célibataires
les plus convoitées au monde et à brad
pitt et à tom cruise et maintenant il ya
cyril hanouna
mais c'est quoi cette histoire s'est
passée une vanne vous allez vous dire
c'est une vanne obama c'est quoi cette
photo alors c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est vous quand même j'avais annoncé ça
dans la vente d'art cas alors moi j'ai
pu faire une touffe comme ça ça c'est un
mec le photographe et j'aurai tout sous
pétain maroc à évasion on l'a fait c'est
quoi et après tu regrettes alors c'est
un peu comme c'est un petit peu
équivalent alors y en a bien une qui
doit proposer tout de suite sa
candidature spontanée passer des bimbos
bah ouais sauf qu'avant votre tête je
pense que oui vous êtes prêt pour
l'amour mais pas prêt pour l'amour avec
eric thomas regardez votre réaction
quand elle vous chauffe c'est un
magnifique zumba
à
[Musique]
c'est sociétal aujourd'hui des gens qui
ne veulent plus abordable j'en fais
partie un des préférés des utilisateurs
oui moi aussi s'attend à rien
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
zola qui toi je maquille pas je peux le
dire ce soir c'était une connerie
voilà je ne suis pas célibataire voilà
je ne suis pas célibataire aller au
québec c'est bon c'est bon ça me saoule
et assez bon est-ce que je suis là pour
parler de ma vie j'ai c'est quelqu'un de
connu à donner autant d où toi tu
attends un célibataire voilà il est
célibataire mais voilà les babines
thoraval inquiéter les vitamines thomas
va t'appeler j'ai deux sujets ont parlé
de fouet
non pas parce que nous on se livre tout
le temps oui tout ça là en tant que
délégué du personnel
j'en ai alors il a séjourné à droite on
retire la pu prendre un café
les trois you que vous donniez aussi de
vous dans des trucs personnels avant des
commandes au niveau du français
ça se passe en fait les cherry à tout va
bien et on ne parle pas de ça bien
entendu on n'est pas là pour ça les gars
vous vous passionnez c'est un sujet de
roman d'intrigué d'accord il
additionnant son public mais vous avez
été conçu entre le 21 décembre c'est le
2 janvier 73
[Rires]
j'ai calculé lune vous êtes vous
on est calme au niveau de sa lune c'est
bon c'est bon ça suffit
non mais je vais appeler votre maman
pour savoir la belle à la plus ténue
oui
arrivé à éliminer voilà vous avec ça
arrêtez avec ça quoi dosettes qu'alain
vous êtes préliminaire on sait rien sur
vous
jamais jamais enquêté enquêter voilà la
vraie nature voilà mr vous êtes dessus
sandrine quétier qui sont les enquêteurs
et qu'il était plus utile a dit alors
s'il savait chanter fabien lecoeuvre ont
été parfaits dans un bus quitte je suis
persuadé vous savez que je fais un peu
leur créateur du blog fans de la légende
fabien lecoeuvre points comme et j'ai
d'ailleurs le plaisir vous annoncer que
nous avons dépassé les 12 visiteurs sur
le blog non ça cartonne 18 morts ici
alors j'ai remarqué que fabien avait
tout pour faire du cinéma alors j'ai
décidé de l'intégrer dans des films
regardés dans un pré générique jean marc
ela superbe posture que prenez fabien
lecoeuvre regarder
[Musique]
les virées ya pas que dans les westerns
crois bien le corps aurait pu jouer
[Musique]
si lindsay liban
alors les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ne rêve
que de devenir astronaute aux pompiers
n'ont ils rêvent de devenir jean michel
maire c'est pour bien gagner leur vie
sans rien [ __ ]
est ce que j'aime chez vous jean michel
c'est qu'en fait vous en cachez pas et
pareil pour les goûts vous en cachez pas
non plus parlant de mathieu on sait que
sa passion c'est lui même et la passion
de jean michel c'est vous cyril je pense
qu'il est temps de regarder une nouvelle
session du faux fayot
[Musique]
alors de la masse disparaît et qu'elle
se transforme en énergie ça fait une
énergie colossale et ce phénomène on
observe ou lanta filante dans les
étoiles
en perdant cyril la lumière que s'est il
passé est une question d'actualité
bousculades et cohues oui que provoquer
vous déjà paraissant public brandon top
5 de ce qui a marqué les années canal
jean michel merde c'est votre choix
c'est quoi à titre perso j'aurais pris
le hanouna et chose que franchement
c'est pour moi c'est ces combats la plus
grande peur de votre vie la plus grande
peur que vous ayez vu dans votre vie
vous il ya deux ans j'avais eu lieu à
pas une coupure de presse me disais vous
aviez arrêté pmp année matin j'étais
habité dans une école à côté de chez moi
la maîtresse demande est-ce qu'à des
gens qui ont été voir sur le plateau tpm
pms bousquet thème une émission un grand
j ai vu qu était déjà venu avait encore
des étoiles dans les yeux de nous avoir
vus
[Musique]
ap
aussi la faille est pareil
toi qui sont les gens ce que tu sois
sincère ses vis-à-vis de moi non bas et
je sais que c'est un pote et moi tu
cherches pas alors ce qui est bien avec
vous c'est que vous êtes patient de
prendre quelques accélérations
servez avec les invités vous êtes une
patience infinie chanteuse préférée
evangeline jeudi dernier les mauvaises
langues disent qu'à vous agacer ses
roches l'adorent mais elle vous à agacer
les gens qui y est ça c'est faux vous à
casser les yeux mais bien sûr mais aussi
je pense en fait qu'elle voulait juste
vous c'est dur pour devenir chroniqueuse
donc elle a mis le paquet au début vous
le défendez face à castres mais au final
c'est vous qui allez être le plus
randonnant regardez c'est ma ba et eve
alors au début des questions vous
n'aimez pas du tout que benjamin de
funès s'attaque à eve angeli même si peu
plus la supporter je suis passionné
montfort bisous et vendu elie merci oui
c'est tout pourtant je vole alors
[Rires]
il faut jamais aller aux amours vous
trompez démission c'est vous c'est qui
prenait le relais et qui ne peut plus
cacher que vous aimez beaucoup avant
johnny mais plutôt quand aller chez elle
tu vois bien que ça rentre joué très
bien l'homme amoureux alors vous n'avez
pas dit et voilà sur quoi le ministre de
la justice voudrait appuyé attendait
d'un événement c'est de la merde en
boite et le méro de la saison pour moi
c'est quand ils vendent des dépenses
qu'elle va chanter c'est le plus gros
vent de l'histoire de la télé mondiale
va se retrouver tout de suite à pour
balances ton poste avec yann moix qui
sera en direct avec les milieux boisés
tout tu vas revenir chanter de danser
tout 6 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce qu'ils adorent ils vous diront que
c'est vrai je me suis demandée ce n'est
pas bien parfois autour de la table je
me suis posé la question des données la
réponse n'est pas la pratique non non
voilà mon nom là mais j'aimerais bien
qu'ils reviennent
je voulais c'est vrai je les contacte
alors une belle table je les contacter
et ce matin jeudi jeremiah qu'elle
revienne aux deux fois pour voir comment
ça se passe a répondu c'est la voir elle
était chaude échaudé mais elle ne ferme
pas la porte
elle n'est pas là matthieu delormeau
début de l'animation bon ben ça fait 15
ans quand même qui débute mais en
chroniqueur et lunar il est long et les
brouilles mais en chroniqueur est au
dessus du lot franchement c'est ce que
je pense mais ce qui est magnifique
c'est que lui aussi le pense
ils pensent qu'ils au dessus de l'eau
parce qu'ils s'aiment énormément mais je
vais vous prouver qu'il aime aussi
énormément ses collègues ses collègues
que c'est cool et ça n'existe pas c'est
juste qu'il le montre à sa manière voici
matthieu delormeau mois bo est méchant
[Musique]
alain mathieu n'hésite pas de mettre en
valeur son amie kelly les 12 lits kelly
question juteux peau voilà c'est dit de
plus deux caissettes son meilleur ami
dans l'émission c'est bien sûr jean
michel maire allez ça se voie directe on
fait pas une belle chanson parce qu'on
est amoureux non c'est parce qu'on vient
d'être quittée pendant ces journées
pourraient faire les albums dès son
arrivée le courant est tout de suite
passé entre matthieu delormeau fabien
lecoeuvre
est-ce que vous avez une star vous qui
avez un rituel non non il fait un truc
voilà nombre que moi j'ai rien moi qui
prends ta bille mal mais le chroniqueur
qui ressort le plus d'amour de la part
de match assez bien sûr benjamin
castaldi dernier répond 1,10 au 10 euros
que reste-t-il à castaldi a précédé
force mentale mais plus bas que les
autres
[Musique]
m
allez alors on a la chance d'avoir avec
nous quelques fois doc gynéco à son
corps est avec nous mais son esprit
était là mais il donne tout quand il a
aidé parfois il est tellement fatigués
d'avoir sorti sept mois d'affilée que il
dormait les jeux ouverts notamment
pendant un débat avec christophe
hondelatte
c'est le retour de doc gynéco c'était
bon sa fin on se souvient 4 à côté de
pierre jean chalencon ça avait tendance
à endormir doc gynéco souvenez vous on
avait parlé depuis quelques mois
christophe hondelatte raconte tellement
bien les histoires que doc gynéco se
laisse complètement versées et je crois
qu'il y avait tant nous une rationalité
qui n'oublie mais non ce type s'est
suicidé et puis une folie qui nous dit
peut-être qu'il a reconstruit et c
[Musique]
il est temps
il étend ses motos les plus basses alors
j'ai pris le taxi ce week-end parce que
j'ai un peu d'argent de poche de mes
parents et le chauffeur que j'embrasse
me dit et c'est sérieux j'adore le
tarbes à bascous penser que cyril va
gagner jusqu'à la fin de la saison bah
je lui ai répondu que malheureusement
l'histoire risque et de s'arrêter
aujourd'hui musique de suspense à peine
de l'enrochement c'est plus facile que
peut-être maintenant dans l'une fait
encore une très belle émission
alors si je sais que votre rêve ultime
est de devenir le tabac pour la 19e fois
consécutive
c'est vrai que depuis l'arrivée de
fabien je suis un petit peu je doute je
doute mais pas dû faire pas mal il est
armé par l'art 19e vaincu plus tard
[Applaudissements]
pantani 20 noeuds est ce que j'adore
c'est il applaudit comme si j'avais
cognac ou soit à fond c'est plus dur ce
que vous faites vous que ce qui fait lui
annoncé sur ce qu'il fait lui regarder
la dystonie d'un grand lit ah ouais je
sois pas dans un édito du doigt ou une
cabine à uv à côté elle dort dans un
cercueil
je suis assez d'accord avec ce que dit
avec valérie alors je pars de la télé
oui c'est vrai 17
joli l éventuelle et vénéneuse et quitte
le pauvre c'est la victime qui est
traqué par angelina jolie en parlant des
ventes on a quelqu'un qui va intervenir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
muriel pénicaud kiss & kill muriel
pénicaud et du travail bien sûr bien sûr
elle ne vous concerne pas le téléthon
une enquête d'action hier son w9 juste
après que poussent comme ça amener du
stère adore fait son retour ce soir
maxime ghenim ce qui se passe c'est la
couleur qui vous gêne non c'est la barre
de la personne
[Applaudissements]